hello I'm Anna Jones and you're watching
a 360 degree tour of Westminster Abbey
the site of the coronation of King
Charles III
looking down from high up in the Abbey
you can see the path the new king will
walk with the eyes of the world looking
on just as his mother Queen Elizabeth II
did seven decades ago back at ground
level in the Nave behind us is the Great
West door where King Charles will enter
to begin the coronation service
he'll walk past the Tomb of the Unknown
Soldier an unidentified member of the
military who fell during the first World
War
while it looks quiet now the king won't
be alone
he'll join more than 2 200 people at the
Abbey including representatives from 203
countries heads of state and community
and charity workers
the king will walk through the choir
screen the Abbey's organ above
he'll walk through the choir before
taking his place in front of the high
Altar for the service led by the
Archbishop of Canterbury
as we pause here in front is the high
Altar and the cosmati pavement first
constructed in 1268 on the orders of
King Henry III
this is working Charles III will spend
the majority of the two-hour service
to the left you can see the great North
Door
as we look down again on the Abbey you
can see the scale of the cosmati
pavement
and as we return to the choir area you
can see once again the path King Charles
will walk for his coronation
you can follow the event as it happens
on Sky News TV our mobile app website
and our social channels